vous qui avez travaillé sur sûr beaucoup
qui avait fait de deux émissions de
téléréalité
est-ce que vous avez vu de la drogue est
ce que vous avez bu de l'alcool en toute
honnêteté mais non non sur la dernière
émission qu'on a fait sans parler de
netflix netflix et 4ème en personne va
en entendre parler
sûreté fixé sur la bataille des coupes
non non et si la production on aurait vu
je pense qu'ils auraient pris les
mesures nécessaires pour que le
sentiment que vous en avez vu un certain
j'en ai vu passer oui quoi c'est à dire
quoi de la drogue la drogue l'alcool il
ya quoi sur les tournages
alors il ya des clans moi je peux pas
dire que la prod fournis se seraient mis
d'accord donc sur moi parce que j'ai vu
des candidats devant moi le faire et moi
khiter quoi ils prenaient quoi j'ai vu
plusieurs drogues dures c'est à dire la
cocaïne ecstasy est bon allez joint ça
c'est tous les tournages ça c'est ce que
nous a dit un employé - vous avez eu de
la cocaïne aussi ah oui oui et j'ai vu
certains comment ils seraient rentrés
même quand c'est dans des pays étrangers
commandant luc sorties sorties dans le
sou mais non mais non non non
sérieusement
par exemple dimanche on avait le droit
de faire venir de la nourriture de
l'extérieur commander des pizzas essayer
de faire comprendre en la langue à la
personne et j'ai vu de mes yeux faire
rentrer après le dimanche d'après les
données des petits sachets tout ça avec
les pizzas et j'ai vu sortir des
benjamins vous qui connaissez bien il ya
de la drogue y avait là de la cocaïne
dans le vrai problème c'est que ça fait
vingt ans maintenant que telle et rêver
est en france il ya effectivement depuis
vingt ans des rumeurs oui on va pas se
mentir les les
les jeunes prennent de la drogue
pourquoi ils adorent d'en prendre dans
une maison donc ils vont rentrer je suis
absolument certain série de jouets droit
dans les yeux que la prod soit bannie
des que ce soit les autres
jamais la prod n'est complice de sa mort
mais maintenant je peux vous dire moins
nous on a vécu parce que son sursis
crête on s'est rendu compte de la façon
de diviser rentrée de la came de la cam
dur alors justement on va voir la
réponse parce que la mairie nous
accueillir la production et donc jeudi
c'est impossible jolie franchement
isc validé une fois parce que vous parce
que je veux pas d'histoires mais on
accumule des heures 10 tv des fois on
n'a pas le temps de les faire et du coup
à la fin du tournage sont qui est des
heures et j'ai vu un candidat prendre un
cachet 1 et la journaliste qui fasse un
bon façon j'en ai marre faut accélérer à
les bases ici ça t'aide à aller plus
vite
non monsieur vous pouvez regarder aura
on a on a une personne qui a travaillé
pour différentes boîtes de production de
télé réalité vous avez travaillé merci
d'être avec moi vous appelez max merci
d'être là soit bon sens vous avez
travaillé sur beaucoup d'émissions
notamment sur les anges alors vous
travaillez encore sur la télé réalité ou
pas vous avez été témoin d'actes de
harcèlement ou d'acharnement donc voilà
c'est un petit peu sérieuse puisque et
rejoint ce qu'on s'est dit en en prenant
les deux les deux témoignages un conte a
eu avant-hier here
quelle est la position de la production
vis-à-vis de sa de l'acharnement pour
pas que ça se transforme en harcèlement
si difficilement des clash
d'accord ça se passe comment quand les
caméras sont éteintes
est ce qu'il ya des gros clash skd
bagarre est ce qu'il ya des choses qu'on
a qui ont été dévoilées ici par les
trois heures fixes on lui doit en offre
avant-hier qui m'ont toujours beaucoup
les sens alors vous allez participer à
la bataille des couples avec notamment
raphaël qui est devenu un très bon ami à
vous avec lui mais non ça c'est ma tin
horse pas aimé vous parce qu'il ya max
et maxime donc ces exécutions ils sont
cons voilà et mais vous vous connaissez
vous avez travaillé donc avec avec avec
raphaël ou pas
moi j'ai loupé oui et comment ça se
passait avec me rappelle quelqu'un qui
voit pas qui accompagne drogue voilà
c'est vrai c'est quelqu'un qui a un fort
tempérament qui doit par des accès de
colère il arrivait qu'il s'appelle
froide et faible ne pas y participer
d'accord dont vous allez venez d vous
avez voilà des des comportements ckoi
virulent mais c'est quoi virulence et sa
violence avant ses propos dans ses
gestes
c'est à dire que plusieurs fois il a pu
s'approcher candidate sa simulation
c'est violent donc voilà c'est la
divination intimidations violences
vu l'intérêt d'assurer sion d'accord
problème c'est que vous aviez pris la
voie de bercy alors en fait il ya des
productions je me suis senti beaucoup
plus protégés hors caméra mais dans les
anges étaient clairement en insécurité
et je suis sûr que a prêché pas des fois
la preuve ça doit tomber des fois c'est
pas tout le temps comme ça mais moi ce
que j'ai vécu c'était vraiment une
angoisse terrible ne pas être protégée
hors caméra j'avais peur à wels qu'est
venue la dernière fois chez vous elle
m'a somme une fois hors caméra la nounou
elle dormait au plomb peut régler le
problème de son valentin stocker
origines merci patio alors oui donc à
wayne elle m'a sauvé hors caméra il ya
un candidat qui devait d'ailleurs même
fait dans la maison qui était qui avait
fait son départ eh ben ils étaient là ce
sens là il m'a sauté dessus comme
maintenant le mec qui fait fait un mètre
90 j'ai cru qu'ils allaient m'éclater la
gueule c'est raul qui m'a défendu sur
les paroles sur la production ils font
rien sans rien c'est la mobilisation
n'était même plus la base dans la maison
alors c'est pas normal c'est pas dans
les flashs bénévoles à tf1 il ya eu
plein débordements et on a géré
effectivement l'alcool parce qu'au début
c'était un peu open bar sur le loft à
prendre a fait des abdos effectivement
donner un verre par
candidat mais à chaque fois qui a eu le
moins débordements en deux secondes
il y avait des mois je vous dis même ce
que vous racontez là où la ligne en
vainqueur et des moeurs l'avait repart
candidats doivent pas rester deux mois
sans boire arrêté avec moi quand les
caméras et n'importe quoi excusez moi
benjamin et moi moi je moi je vous dise
quitté la rai même quand on vit les mecs
quand on dit quand j'entends des
arguments oui ils sont jeunes ils
doivent se droguer mais on est où là ici
c'est ça les mecs vous êtes fou quoi et
c'est pas la prod qui fournit non mais
tous mine de rien vous savez ce qui se
passe ouais on arrivé là bas
et vous arrêtez s'il vous dit les mecs
si les candidats le savent la prod le
c'est donc moi dans mon cas moi je vous
jure que c'est vrai sur six est fleuri à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu des problèmes
d'alcool et de drogue je vous jure que
c'est vrai parce que autour du puits les
enfoncer parfois je voulais que chaque
fois c'était totalement totalement géré
totalement à chaque fois vraiment on
peut les fonds sont vraiment calé une
caméra et scoop ils se rejoignent tous
en bas il boit de la vodka moi je prends
une douche je vais me coucher mamie
ginette et c'est moi l'âge
extraterrestres et même couché alors
posé la question on va poser la question
latente et moi qui pour l'instant
vous avez vu d'ici on a ce qu'on a pu
voir à ce qu'on a pu ressentir toussaint
ici alors juste et ce qu'il ya de la
drogue au sein du programme des anges
voilà donc qui en a la drogue quoi on a
alors parce que y'a raphaël qui nous
apparaît cannabis et il ya angèle qui
nous a parlé de coco caïds voilà donc
une chance si vous êtes vous étiez au
courant vous vous étiez de produits où
vous étiez au courant aussi qu'il y
avait de la drogue dea des drogues dures
notamment dans ses émissions
vous étiez vous donc vous faisait partie
de la production et vous saviez que la
production était au courant qu'il y
avait des drogues dures dans ses pensées
dans cette émission
hercules et nicolas ce qui est en train
de dire et un est un véritable scandale
puisque vous savez bien que c'est filmé
donc c'est à dire que tous les complices
de ce qui se passe sur ses plateaux vous
savez bien que même un verre inverse
aujourd'hui d'alcool est interdite sur
ce plateau
donc c'est interdit partout donc je suis
effaré d'entendre ce qu'a dit hier
raphaël en disant oui à peut-être un
verre de temps en temps non mais elle ça
n'est pas la mer c'est vrai elle a dit
la vérité
barman il paraît qu'il boit pas et qui
ne sait pas mais qu'il ait dit hier
naturellement qu'il y avait
effectivement des verts qui peut les
belges il est aujourd'hui certains
messages ecam le ce programme est là
elle a t-on par y larguent voilà un
parle de drogue
je veux dire il ya quand même des
producteurs derrière il ya quand même
des images il ya quand même des
changements le comportement il ya comme
un public derrière derrière ce genre de
programme et vous mènera le tweet est
mal mélenchon mais quand je vois sur
twitter qu'on a l'air étonné de ce qui
se passe sur les plateaux je vais vous
dire un truc
oui je suis étonné oui je suis
scandalisé oui tu la prends aujourd'hui
c'est parce que j'ai vu sur twitter des
gens ce qui se passe quand on a une
autre candidate ya quelques années qui
nous l'avait dit mais oui on tombe des
nues ça veut dire que les mecs qui vont
nous dire bah oui mine de rien vous nous
dites que dans une émission
voilà qu énormément regarder de
l'ecstasy de la cocaïne valérie non mais
moi je trouve ça absolument absolument
dingue est évidemment que je crois ce
monsieur qui nous parle là qui nous dit
que la chose n'est pas celle qui fournit
bien évidemment mais celles qui ferment
les yeux haussier moi je trouve que une
production qui fait les yeux est tout
aussi responsable pardon mais
normalement on n'a pas à fermer les yeux
puisque moi je ne sais pas si il ya des
gens de la production qui reste h 24
dans ces maisons mais moi je pense que
normalement elle devrait rester y
compris la nuit mais on veut dire salut
il alors s'ils en ont pris la nuit tout
le temps on devrait ce qu'il ya dans les
valises on devrait et peu importe qu'ils
soient majeurs ont pas majeur ça devrait
être une charte de bonne conduite
on devrait vérifier on devrait ouvrir
les vannes nîmes et on devrait les
bretons ont dit ça pourquoi on dit ça 1
déjà l'exemple et est déplorable mais
deux ça change des comportements c'est
bien sûr je suis désolé moi quand vous
dites est un verre d'alcool par personne
key à la plein gré qu'est ce que vous
savez que vous avez qui en a pas un qui
me rembarre 4 et qui va être
complètement non moi je m'appelle
prennent pas exactement c'est ça elle
boit pas et prennent son verre voilà que
je le sais vous croyez que ça se passe
comme ça je le sais très bien et après
ils ont des comportements violents
et puis on sait très bien que
la drogue surtout des drogues comme ça
gilles sachant que les comportements
totalement et ces mêmes encouragées à
partir du moment où une production même
si elle n'a introduit par la drogue ou
l'alcool
c'est elle c'est qu'elle n'agit pas elle
cautionne est légitime elle encourage
mais si benjamin vous le savez très bien
la production et défendre sa jeune oui
je ne comprends pas je défends pas je ne
défends pas je vous dise qu'il ya une
production avec milan responsable il ya
des gens autour qui bossent peut-être
que des débordements oui il y en a une
série à part les séries ça fait 20 ans
qu'on sait que j'arrivais tout jacques
tu veux dire des pailles et vous non
serré mais arrêtez ça va mal
sinon je suis d'être bien entouré je
suis choquée qu'ils aient la drogue sur
les programmes je trouve ça ça me change
et c'est du vin en verre orange par
contre mais oui le système qui veut ça
les gens ils constateront de la drogue
sur les océans donc pour l'habitude de
prendre de l'héroïne
géorgie dominée 2 voilà ce soir je sais
pas pour vous mais je marche sur la tête
lang a dit bah oui mais ils ont
l'habitude de ces fictions secrète il
est engagé à de nouveaux arrêts effitic
sydney c'est difficile parce que tu es
fx côte est engagé tout le monde sait
tout le monde sait que bin qui a dicté
et ballon rond le prend pas c'est parce
que dans les questions étaient légitimes
et que des gens prennent de la drogue au
monde je vous dirais entre un père et un
poids main mais là mais la drôle de la
drogue de l'alcool en méharée la ville